[Aplausos]
[Música]
estoy seguro de que todos absolutamente
todos habéis visto mensajes y titulares
como
estos queridos amigos amigas la
Argentina tiene nuevo presidente el
libertario Javier Miley lo que por
supuesto ha provocado todo tipo de
reacciones hablamos de un tipo cuya
carrera ha sido meteórica de ser
prácticamente un desconocido a
convertirse apenas unos años después en
el mismísimo presidente y ojo no un
presidente cualquiera sino uno que llega
al poder con una promesa totalmente
rupturista cambiar por completo todo el
sistema político económico y social de
la Argentina es decir que milei llega
como una especie de bulldozer con una
misión tan Clara como ambiciosa derribar
de una vez por todas las bases
fundamentales del peronismo lo mejor de
todo es que milei no solo era un
desconocido sino que además logró esta
gesta sin pertenecer a ninguna de las
históricas formaciones políticas del
país lo hizo montando su propio partido
la libertad avanza queridos amigos
amigas la cuestión es que tal como
habéis visto son muchos los medios
analistas y políticos que lo tachan de
formar parte de la extrema derecha pero
realmente se puede decir algo así forma
parte mi ley de la extrema derecha y eso
no es todo habitualmente también se le
compara con bolsonaro Santiago avascal o
el propio Donald Trump muy claramente es
un mini Trump Trump es un icono de esta
nueva forma de populismo extremo y mi
ley quiere y lógicamente La pregunta es
hasta qué punto se parece Javier milei a
Donald Trump J bolsonaro o incluso
Santiago vascal realmente tiene el león
argentino tantas similitudes con el
expresidente de Estados Unidos el
expresidente de Brasil o el candidato de
vox en España desde luego a tenor de
mensajes como este podríamos decir que
mucho Donald Trump es uno de los pocos
que ha entendido la batalla contra el
socialismo dar pelea asimilando las
restricciones de estado las
autoinflingido local e internacional
Bueno pero algunos solo critican mirando
títulos falsos Muchas gracias presidente
Trump su presidencia fue un ejemplo para
todos los que defendemos las ideas de la
libertad y espero conocerlo pronto no
tenga dudas de que vamos a hacer
Argentina grande otra vez viva la
libertad nuestro alineamiento de
geopolítica es Estados Unidos e Israel
esa es nuestra política internacional
nosotros no nos vamos a alinear con
comunistas como veis el propio Miley ha
expresado muchas veces su simpatía por
todo toos estos actores políticos y
desde luego ellos tampoco han ocultado
la suya por el movimiento que lidera el
nuevo presidente argentino
fijaos ara
Again para
Felicidades querido milei Por tu gran
Victoria en las elecciones
presidenciales argentinas hoy se abre un
camino de futuro y Esperanza para los
argentinos y toda iberoamérica que
celebramos en España con especial
alegría sin embargo queridos amigos no
vayamos tan de
prisa Es verdad que podemos ver una
Clara coincidencia de estilo tanto Miley
como Trump como bolsonaro o abascal
suelen tener un tono muy duro son
agresivos y todos ellos se posicionan
como una alternativa al sistema en
cierto modo comparten un cierto tinte
populista todos ellos se caracterizan
por elegir claramente un contrincante un
enemigo destacar luego alguna medida
estrella y casi milagrosa que repiten
hasta la saciedad y enfrentarse a los
medios de comunicación desde un punto de
vista de mensaje político los
inmigrantes de Trump vienen a ser por
decirlo de alguna forma lo mismo que la
casta de Miley pero amigos sabéis qué
que hasta aquí llegan las similitudes Lo
cierto es que los grandes temas en el
posicionamiento y la agenda política
Miley Se parece tanto a Trump bolsonaro
abascal como un huevo a una castaña
Hasta cierto punto Trump bolsonaro Y
abascal sí que tienen muchos más
parecidos sin embargo el nuevo
presidente de Argentina digamos que
forma parte de un club completamente
diferente un momento no me creéis
pensáis que estamos exagerando pues si
os parece empecemos haciendo una
comparación entre milei y Trump Aunque
en la mayoría de los casos esta misma
comparación también se podría aplicar a
bolsonaro o abascal la cosa no cambiaría
mucho prestad mucha atención porque
estas son las siete grandes diferencias
políticas de estos dos líderes que en el
fondo no podrían ser más diferentes
[Música]
atentos Pero antes sabíais que podéis
ayudarnos activamente a seguir creciendo
y creando contenido independiente habéis
oído hablar de nuestro boletín semanal
exclusivo para patronos o de nuestro
merchandising que no está a la venta en
ningún otro sitio pues queridos amigos
amigas Si os gusta lo que hacemos aquí
en visual politic y también en visual
economic y queréis colaborar activamente
con este proyecto ya podéis hacerlo
recibiendo todo esto que os he dicho y
mucho más a cambio en la comunidad de
patrión de visual politic os dejamos el
enlace en la descripción y ahora sí
vamos con
Miley el muro
comercial vale creo que todos sabemos
que este tema es junto a la inmigración
una de las grandes señas de identidad
del 45 presidente de los Estados Unidos
de América y también la primera gran
diferencia que podemos encontrar con
mate Trump es un proteccionista
convencido y lo mismo podríamos decir en
cierto senti de bolsonaro y Santiago
vascal estos tres políticos suelen
hablar constantemente de hacer crecer la
industria local de comprar productos
fabricados en el propio país y bueno
cosas por el estilo de hecho el libre
comercio es uno de los temas que primero
atrajo a trampa la política ya en la
década de los 80 aparecían programas de
televisión denunciando que Japón le
estaba robando a los Estados Unidos con
sus exportaciones por eso cuando en 2015
anunció su candidatura a las primarias
republicanas puso precisamente al
comercio en el centro de su campaña
china nos está matando el dinero que
sacaron de Estados Unidos es el mayor
robo en la historia de nuestro país y
cuando llegó al gobierno Pues bueno
digamos que no se quedó precisamente
corto Trump lanzó una guerra comercial
contra la Unión Europea sacó a Estados
Unidos del tpp el mayor acuerdo de libre
comercio de la historia lanzó una guerra
comercial contra china imponiendo
montones de aranceles y amenazó a
diestro y siniestro con tomas
represarias comerciales al final el
resultado de todas estas medidas fue un
fracaso el déficit comercial siguió
aumentando y según varios estudios la
guerra comercial le costó decenas de
miles de millones de dólares a las
familas norteamericanas Pero bueno eso
ya es otra historia y bueno Vale puede
que ahora alguno esté pensando bueno
Esto Trump lo hizo por aquello o por lo
otro pero realmente no es que tuviera
nada en contra del libre comercio No
pues ahora Trump se ha vuelto a
presentar a las primarias republicanas y
sabéis cuál es una de sus medidas
estrella pues fijaos Trump promete
nuevos aranceles masivos y es elegido
arriesgándose a una guerra económica
mundial Seguro seguro que alguno de
vosotros está pensando vala ya está la
prensa manipulando Otra vez Pues fijaos
en lo que dice el mismo Trump creo que
cuando las empresas entran y vierten sus
productos en los Estados Unidos deberían
pagar automáticamente digamos un
impuesto del 10% Exacto hablamos de que
Trump está defendiendo un arancel
general a cualquier producto que entre
en los Estados Unidos del 10% para que
os hagáis una idea esto supondría más
que triplicar el arancel medio que está
actualmente por debajo del 3% y la
pregunta es qué dice milei sobre este
tema Pues básicamente todo lo
contrario quiere abrir las fronteras
argentinas al comercio internacional de
hecho en su programa de gobierno se ha
comprometido a eliminar aranceles y
cualquier otra restricción al comercio
internacional incluyendo cupos permisos
y autorizaciones incluso sobre el
mercosur mi ley ha llegado a decir cosas
como estas yo creo que hay que eliminar
el mercosur porque es una Unión aduanera
defectuosa que perjudica a los
argentinos de bien o sea es en el fondo
es un comercio administrado por Estados
para favorecer empresarios prebendario
así que ya lo veis primera gran
diferencia entre mi ley y Donald Trump
[Música]
sigamos cerrad El Banco
Central queridos amigos Si antes
decíamos que el proteccionismo era toda
una seña de identidad del tramp mismo
creo que nadie tendrá la menor duda de
que la eliminación del Banco Central
para que los políticos no puedan meter
mano en él es uno de los grandes rasgos
políticos de Javier Miley de hecho el
nuevo presidente argentino hizo de la
dolarización y el cierre del Banco
Central su política estrella fue algo
que defendió BM
vaya si lo hizo el Banco Central está
haciendo de las suyas de
nuevo creo que es fuera de serr
destrucción destrucción destrucción
destrucción destrucción
destrucción
milei culpa al Banco Central de muchos
de los grandes males de la economía
Argentina Empezando por la inflación
Bueno mejor dicho culpa la capacidad de
los políticos de utilizar el Banco
Central para mangonear financiar todos
sus caprichos Y monetizar la deuda
pública según mi ley eso ha destrozado
el peso y las finanzas argentinas Pues
bien sabéis Qué Que tran defiende
básicamente lo contrario Sí sí me habéis
oído
[Música]
bien una de las grandes y constantes
críticas de Donald Trump durante su
etapa en la casa blanca fue precisamente
la independencia de la reserva Federal
Trump intentó constantemente presionar
les para que imprimiera más y más dinero
bajaran los tipos e incluso monetizar la
deuda Federal la reserva Federal debería
reducir nuestras tasas de interés a cero
o menos y luego deberíamos comenzar a
refinanciar nuestra deuda sabemos que
hice mucha presión fue una presión
externa porque nadie sabe si realmente
puedes hacer eso o no pero lo hice
porque pensé que sus tipos de interés
eran demasiado altos finalmente bajaron
sus tipos de interés y ojo que los tipos
llegaron a un máximo del 2 y5 por
mientras la economía norteamericana
crecía a buen ritmo y aún así Trump se
quejaba y presionaba la reserva Federal
una y otra y otra vez entendéis ahora
cómo se empezó a cocinar la crisis de la
inflación El caso es que el expresidente
lo hizo durante su tiempo en la casa
blanca y lo vuelve a hacer ahora otra
vez como candidato en las primarias
republicanas Trump se lamenta de las
altas tasas de interés E indica que
podría presionar a la reserva Federal
para que bajen independencia del Banco
Central ja prima más dinero ese era uno
de los grandes caballos de batalla de
Trump porque sabía que a corto plazo eso
estimularía la economía lo que mejoraría
su nivel de popularidad ojo no lo
decimos nosotros lo decía el mismo la
gente no puede comprar casas no pueden
hacer nada quiero decir no pueden pedir
prestado dinero insisto hablamos de
tipos en el entorno del 2% y la cuestión
es que te parezca mejor o te parezca
peor la opinión de mi ley en esto es
exactamente la contraria nada de
imprimir más dinero nada de inflar
artificialmente la economía y nada de
monetizar deuda pública otra diferencia
importante no os parece Claro que no
hemos terminado de hecho el empeño de
Trump con que la reserva Federal
expandiera la oferta monetaria tiene
mucho pero que mucho que ver con los
siguientes dos puntos
atentos Más
[Música]
madera vale tanto Trump como milei y
también bolsonaro y avascal hablan de
bajar impuestos eso a priori puede ser
un punto en común sin embargo se apoya
en una diferencia fundamental milei
quiere bajar impuestos compensando la
caída de los ingresos públicos con
recortes en el gasto pero en el caso de
Trump eso no es así Trump quería que la
reserva Federal bajase los tipos
imprimiera más dinero y comprara más
deuda pública Y por qué lo quiso Pues
precisamente para financiar su creciente
déficit de hecho el crecimiento del
déficit anual se sitúa como el mayor
aumento en relación al tamaño de la
economía de todos los presidentes de la
historia de Estados Unidos solo le
adelantan George Washington y Abraham
Lincoln pero con una gran diferencia
Trump no tuvo que hacer frente a guerras
dentro del propio país así Así que
digamos que el expresidente
norteamericano bajaba año tras año el
gasto público pero mientras además
bajaba los impuestos es decir un boquete
presupuestario enorme para que os hagáis
una idea cuando llegó a la casa blanca
el déficit era del 2,5 pero en 2019 el
déficit alcanzó ya el 4,6 y todo ello
Pese a que el país crecía y aún no había
llegado a la pandemia y esto supone una
gran diferencia con Javier milei porque
para milei el déficit cero y reducir el
gasto público son una absoluta prioridad
y luego para colmo pues llegó la
pandemia
la
montaña por la montaña no nos referimos
a las rocosas ni nada por el estilo sino
a la enorme montaña de deuda que siguió
acumulando Donald Trump durante apenas 4
años de gobierno la deuda pública creció
en casi 7,8 billones de dólares más de
20,000 por habitante una locura Y no
solo eso cuando luego llegó la pandemia
Trump mostró claramente Cómo defendía
enfrentarse a una crisis gastando
toneladas y toneladas de dinero público
incluso llegó a enviar cheques a las
familias para que se lo gastaran y de
hecho los datos son contundentes tan
solo la respuesta del Gobierno Federal a
la crisis de la covid siguiendo el plan
de Trump superó el 8% del pib por
comparar entre 1933 y 1939 el gasto
Federal creció bajo el New deal del
presidente Roosevelt en aproximadamente
un 5% del pib y luego la respuesta a la
gran recesión del 2008
equivaliendo
aún más disparada
insisto Esto es algo que te puede gustar
más o te puede gustar menos valorar
estas medidas no es la intención de este
vídeo la cuestión es que de nuevo va en
dirección contraria a lo que defiende
Miley no se negocia el equilibrio fiscal
el equilibrio fiscal no está bajo
discusión ministro que me gasta más lo
hecho no sé si soy claro ministro que
gasta más lo hecho el 2024 va a terminar
con equilibrio fiscal además como Trump
tenía que financiar este enorme boquete
presupuestario entonces presionaba la
reserva Federal para que bajara tipos y
comprara deuda pública en este aspecto
la posición de Trump era más parecida a
la de Sergio masa que a la de Javier
Miley así que ya lo veis ni en lo que se
refiere al Banco Central ni a la forma
de bajar impuestos ni al nivel de gasto
público ni en lo que se refiere al nivel
de deuda pública ni tampoco el comercio
internacional m y Trump tienen
posiciones compartidas más bien como
veis están en las antípodas Claro que
queridos amigos amigas No todo es la
economía el aborto
[Música]
milei lo tiene muy claro y no se corta
un pelo dice que el aborto es un
asesinato y está furiosamente en contra
incluso ha prometido un referéndum para
dar marcha atrás a la legalización que
se aprobó en Argentina en el año 2020
estoy en contra del aborto abiertamente
porque va en contra del derecho a la
vida el nuevo presidente argentino ha
llegado a decir que las personas que
están a favor del aborto tienen y cito
literalmente el cerebro lavado por una
política asesina Y qué hay de Donald
Trump bueno Pues digamos que no tiene
una posición tan Clara ni tampoco es
algo prioritario para él en 1999 por
ejemplo defendió públicamente el derecho
a decidir de las
mujeres con
ABS es decir una posición muy similar a
la que por ejemplo tiene Joe biden Es
verdad que Trump se jacta de que Bajo su
gobierno se escogieron a jueces
conservadores para el tribunal supremo y
que eso hizo caer la conocida doina de
Row contra W de 1973 que reconocía el
derecho de la mujer a abortar ahora bien
si se jacta de esto último es porque
Trump sabe que no puede renunciar al
apoyo de muchos sectores conservadores
de su país pero al mismo tiempo el
propio Donald rechaza apoyar una
restricción nacional y de hecho ahora en
campaña podemos encontrar mensajes como
este Trump llama la prohibición del
aborto de de santis un terrible error lo
que ha provocado la ira de algunos
republicanos clave y antes esto rond de
santis no ha tardado en responder no sé
cómo puede siquiera hacer la afirmación
de que eres provida si estás criticando
a los Estados por promulgar protecciones
para los bebés que tienen latidos del
corazón Así que ya lo veis otro tema
donde mile y Trump juegan en ligas
diferentes pero
[Música]
sigamos qu no
pasen vale Si antes decíamos que el
proteccionismo era una de las señas de
identidad del tramp mismo creo que todos
coincidiremos en que la inmigración es
la otra gran característica de este
movimiento Trump no quiere inmigrantes
ojo de ningún tipo defiende acabar con
la inmigración ilegal pero también
restringir y limitar la inmigración
legal de hecho la forma de hablar que
tiene hacia las personas que llegan del
extranjero no es precisamente muy
acogedora y de hecho su candidatura para
2024 pasa precisamente por eso mismo por
restringir a más la inmigración tanto
ilegal como legal por supuesto habla de
deportar a millones y millones de
personas la posición de Javier Miley En
cambio es otra vez muy pero que muy
diferente de entrada es conceptual e
ideológicamente partidario de sistemas
de inmigración mucho más abiertos en su
opinión El único problema que tiene la
inmigración es el coste que esta tiene
para los servicios sociales hay
documentos que prueban que aquellos
países que son más abiertos tienen mayor
Innovación crecen más con lo cual la
inmigración es algo bueno cuando
vinieron nuestros abuelos o nuestros
padres vinieron a ganarse el pan con el
sudor de la frente y no había estado de
bienestar el problema arranca con la
inmigración cuando hay estado de
bienestar por eso ha dicho que si
existiera por ejemplo un sistema de
vouchers generalizados o un sistema
privado entonces apoyaría prácticamente
un régimen de inmigración abierta otra
vez es una posición que está en las
antípodas de Trump pero queridos amigos
amigas aún nos queda un último punto
atentos Ucrania y Tiranos
varios a veces Miley ha dicho que apoya
la visión exterior de Donald Trump sin
embargo cuando entramos en detalles la
cosa cambia bastante aquellos que
defendemos sin titubeos un modelo de
soci cedad abierta y libre debemos unir
fuerzas en favor de una estrategia
efectiva para enfrentar a los enemigos
de la libertad que como en el pasado
vuelven a intentar arrastrar a la
humanidad a tiempos oscuros de Caos y
miseria Esto hace que Miley apoye a
Ucrania y a Israel mientras que Trump
Apuesta por parar la ayuda kf
Enhorabuena a milei por su contundente
Victoria en las elecciones
presidenciales de Argentina aprecio su
Clara postura de apoyo a Ucrania Espero
seguir trabajando juntos para fortalecer
nuestra cop operación y restaurar el
orden internacional basado en el derecho
internacional y eso por no hablar de
encuentros como este Seguro seguro que
todos lo recordaréis
verdad Trump dice que el norcoreano Kim
es muy honorable Y qué dice mile Pues
básicamente que con los autoritarismos y
el comunismo no quiere saber
absolutamente nada que a nivel de
comercio privado Pues muy bien que cada
uno comercie lo que quiera con el país
que quiera pero a nivel de gobierno nada
de nada yo no promovería la relación con
comunista ni con Cuba ni con Venezuela
ni con Corea del Norte ni con Nicaragua
ni con
china Así que ya lo veis estas son siete
de las grandes diferencias que existen
entre Trump y milei y también entre
milei bolsonaro y avascal y ojo que como
veis no hablamos precisamente de asuntos
pequeños o intrascendentes sino de
cuestiones absolutamente claves Pilares
fundamentales a la hora de dar forma al
tipo de estado que defienden unos u
otros vale es verdad mile y Trump
también Tienen alguna coincidencia en
asuntos como el cambio climático las
armas o las regulaciones del gobierno
sin embargo pese a todo ello la realidad
es que defienden modelos de sociedad
completamente diferentes y luego pues
qué queréis que os diga te guste más o
te guste menos este personaje y las
políticas que defiende lo de que forme
parte de la extrema derecha que muchos
periodistas dicen Pues bueno qué queréis
que os diga ni por asomo mi ley ha
prometido recortar el gasto público
abrir las fronteras bajar los impuestos
Y cerrar el Banco Central defiende y
promueve la libertad y no tiene ningún
problema por cuestión de género
procedencia o sexualidad Así que la
verdad qué tiene esto de extrema derecha
en todo caso podremos decir que es
ultraliberal libertario Ultra
capitalista pero seamos honestos cuando
hablamos de extrema derecha pensamos en
algo totalmente distinto sea como sea la
pregunta ahora es lo conseguirá déjanos
tu respuesta en los comentarios y
habramos debate y ahora si este vídeo se
ha resultado interesante no olvidéis
darle al botón de like y suscribiros a
visual politic si es que aún no lo
habéis hecho una vez más Muchas gracias
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
[Música]
próxima